xenoblade's combat can be overwhelming
especially if you aren't used to mmo
style battles so i'm gonna do my very
best to break down the basics of combat
from the beginning of a fight to the
very end at its purest form xenoblade
chronicles 3 is all about managing
meters auto attacks and cooldown timers
fill arts meters while well-timed arts
fill the talent meter and a number of
things such as critical hits and
well-timed arts fill the chain attack
gauge but before we get into the
nitty-gritty let's start with something
broad classes there are three different
types of classes in xenoblade chronicles
3 attacker defender and healer those
roles should be pretty self-explanatory
attackers deal high damage defenders
tank enemies and pull aggro and healers
offer support for your party it's
important to keep a good balance of
these three classes at all times classes
are further divided by faction each
class either falls under kevis or agnes
this symbol in the top right corner lets
you know which faction they belong to
for the most part kevis and agnes
classes play the same except for one key
difference kevs class arts are on a
cooldown timer while the cooldown on
agnes class arts are tied to auto
attacks every class has an auto attack
once you're in range of an enemy your
character will attack at a regular
interval different classes have
different auto attack speeds for example
noah's sword fighter class has a
relatively quick auto attack speed
compared to senna's ogre class depending
on the class successful auto attacks
fill your arts meters arts are powerful
abilities that can inflict a large
amount of damage set up combos and heal
and buff party members early on each
class has five unique arts three of
which can be equipped once an art gauge
is full press the corresponding button
to use it however you shouldn't use an
art the second the gauge is full instead
cancel an auto attack into an art to do
this activate an art right as the weapon
makes contact with the enemy if you
timed it right a circle should appear on
the screen canceling auto attacks into
arts and arts into other arts and arts
into talent arts speeds up your attacks
allowing you to do even more damage
[Music]
different arts serve different purposes
and it's important to check an arts
description in the arts menu whenever
you unlock a new class for many
positioning plays a huge role for
example noah's swordfighter class has
two arts that are more effective with
proper positioning sword strike inflicts
break when directed towards the side of
an enemy while edge thrust gets a nice
damage boost from behind if you're ever
unsure as to which angle you're
attacking an enemy from you can
reference the little arrow in the bottom
right corner an arrow pointing up means
you're facing the enemy an arrow
pointing to the side means you're at the
enemy's side and an arrow pointing down
means you are behind the enemy while
positioning is important for every class
attackers typically require the most
precise positioning think about it if
defenders are successfully drawing enemy
aggro then that should give your
attackers and healers free range of the
battlefield arts can also be used to set
up combos across multiple classes and
party members pulling these off requires
precise timing a well-thought-out party
composition and a bit of rng both combo
strings are initiated by a breaker art
noaa's swordfighter class starts the
game with sword strike which as
mentioned earlier inflicts break with
the proper positioning lance can follow
that up with bulrush the heavy guards
topple art from there you have two
options a burst combo or a smash combo
for a burst combo you'd want to follow
up a topple art with a day's art uni's
medic gunner is your best bet here
finally you'll want to hit the dazed
enemy with a burst art successful burst
combos will strip an enemy of its rage
status and they will drop more loot
alternatively once you've toppled an
enemy you can follow it up with a launch
art which sends an enemy into the air in
this short-lived state enemies become
more vulnerable you can finish off the
combo with a smash art which spikes the
enemy back to the ground and delivers a
nice bit of damage
[Music]
[Music]
fortunately you don't have to manually
initiate each art in order to pull off
one of these combos by default your
party will automatically chase these
combos as long as they have the right
arts equipped and they aren't cooling
down you can even hold zr and press left
on the d-pad to specify which combo
you'd like the party to chase i prefer
to play as an attacker because that
means i can usually kick off the combo
by using a breaker art if you'd rather
carry out these combos manually you can
switch between characters mid-battle by
holding zr and using l r early on you
can't actually complete these combos
because you won't have the proper arts
and classes unlocked there are also some
classes that can't contribute to these
combos with their basic arts so keep
this in mind as you tinker with your
team composition for easy reference
breaker topple days bursts launch and
smash arts all have symbols that
indicate their effect to make things a
little easier as you flip through menus
as you land arts and critical hits your
talent art gauge will fill up this is a
powerful art linked to your specific
class like standard arts these can be
cancelled and have a wide range of
effects some can contribute to the
aforementioned combos others can inflict
debuffs on enemies or they can pull
aggro for example this sword fighter's
overclock buster deals extra damage
today's enemies while the ogre's
pressure drop launches a toppled enemy
okay so now we have the basics of
classes auto attacks arts combos and
talent arts these five pillars account
for the moment-to-moment combat gameplay
land auto attacks cancel auto attacks
into arts chain arts together for combos
and utilize talent arts with that out of
the way let's talk master arts and
fusion arts this is where things get a
little more complicated so bear with me
as you level up different classes with
different characters you will unlock
master arts for specific characters for
example if you change noah's class from
the sword fighter to the zephyr you can
unlock zephyr specific arts that noah
can use regardless of his class there
are some restrictions but this means you
could give noah defender arts even if
you think he makes a better attacker
master arts are mapped to the d-pad
however you'll need to level up to
unlock all three master art slots you
can use master arts the same way you
would regular arts or you could combine
them with regular arts to create fusion
arts when you equip master arts be
mindful of where you equip them because
that will determine which art they will
fuse with master arts map to up on the
d-pad will fuse with art map to x right
on the d-pad will fuse with y and down
on the d-pad will fuse with b in order
to use a fusion art first both the
master art and standard art must be
charged then hold zr and press either x
y or b fusion arts are handy because
they deal more damage they combine
status effects buffs and debuffs from
both arts and they can increase your
interlink level we'll get to that later
keep in mind that unlike regular arts
master arts aren't charged at the
beginning of battle meaning you'll have
to wait a bit before you can utilize
them i typically kick off battle using
my standard arts but once i get the ball
rolling i predominantly use fusion arts
you can also set your party members to
prioritize fusion arts by pressing zl
and right on the d-pad at the beginning
of a battle alright let's circle back on
interlinks now new to xenoblade
chronicles 3 is the interlinking
mechanic this allows two compatible
party members to transform into a cool
mech thing while in this state you deal
extra damage and your arts have no
cooldown the catch is that you can only
stay interlinked for a short period of
time before it overheats like standard
arts interlinked arts can be cancelled
into each other in order to fill up a
different talent art gauge normally if
an interlink overheats both party
members will be kicked out of the state
even if they are mid-attack however if
an interlink overheats during a talent
art the interlink will finish the attack
before ejecting both party members i
typically wait until the very last
second to use my talent art in this form
while different inner links serve
different roles all can deal a hefty
amount of damage if used properly there
is an added wrinkle to interlinking
though your interlink level a number
located in the bottom left corner can
improve the effectiveness of your
interlink if you activate a level 3
interlink some arts may have additional
effects for example noaa and mio's
interlink can deal brake damage on all
enemies if the interlink level is at 3.
it's also worth noting that interlink
level resets at the start of a battle or
once an interlink is severed so how do
you level up an interlink fusion arts of
course while fusion arts are more
effective the main reason you should use
fusion arts is to level up your
interlinks this will make your party a
lot more efficient across the board so
with master arts fusion arts and
interlinking out of the way let's move
on to chain attacks
[Music]
chain attacks are nothing new to the
series but they are different this time
around once the chain attack gauge is
full press plus to initiate it this will
pause the battle and let you choose one
of three chain orders or high damage
attacks that have secondary status
effects in order to carry out one of
these chain orders your tp must exceed
100. to do this each conscious party
member will be allowed to attack once
above each party member's portrait is a
number that number represents the base
amount of tp they can contribute to the
tp gauge this number can vary based on a
handful of factors but it will always
start at the number above the portrait
once you exceed 100 tp the chain order
will carry out and you'll start the
process over again the goal is to get
your tp as high as possible while using
as few characters as possible in order
to carry out multiple chain attacks the
longer you can keep a chain attack going
the more damage you'll deal and the more
experience you'll get afterwards classes
also play an important role in chain
attacks if you begin a chain order with
an attacker you'll get a first blood tp
bonus healers will max out your tp at 99
allowing you to carry out additional
attacks completing a chain order with a
defender will reactivate the party
member with the most tp for the next
chain order you also get atp bonus for
utilizing party members that match the
class of the chain order additionally
you can also carry out smash and burst
combos during chain attacks if you have
the right arts equipped how high you get
your tp determines how many characters
are reactivated for the next chain order
100 to 149 will reactivate one party
member 150 to 199 will reactivate two
and 200 and above will reactivate three
the more party members you manage to
reactivate the longer your chain attack
will last and that pretty much covers
chain attacks
just kidding let's talk about auroboros
orders light gameplay spoilers here in
one
two and three okay once you unlock
interlinks with all party members you
can set up oroboros orders by carrying
out chain orders between two party
members that share an interlink form mio
and noah lans and senna and union tion
once both of those paired off characters
complete a chain order an oroboros order
will appear in the chain order selection
screen choosing an oroboros order will
reactivate every party member once
you've maxed out the tp gauge your
interlinked party members will carry out
an incredibly powerful attack the
downside is that the chain attack will
end after an auroboros order unless you
start a chain attack with an oroboros
order if you activate a chain attack
while a level 3 interlink is in use then
you can carry out two auroboros orders
from the interlinked characters now i
found standard chain attacks to be a bit
more effective for my party composition
but if you want to deal a lot of damage
quickly then this is probably the best
way to do it alright i think we've
covered enough ground for today there's
still a lot more to dig into but i think
this is a solid foundation for
first-timers and veterans who might need
a refresher if you'd like to see another
one of these videos let me know in the
comments below in the meantime if you
have any specific xenoblade related
questions feel free to reach out to me
on twitter
jacobdeck thank you so much for watching